okay so there was a video going viral on
Twitter and so many people were weighing
in of a woman being interviewed on the
street street saying she wants a minimum
of $200 for a dinner let's pull it up I
feel like if I'm going to get ready and
I'm going to use all my products to come
out with you I need like a minimum of
$200 a minimum and that's like being
nice and what does a man get in return
for that my
presents what aren't you having his
presents within you already I hear you
but no no I mean like I'm here to get to
know you I'm here to get to know you you
invited me out but he has to drop $200
yeah because minimum yeah just because
just cuz you have to do your
makeup um because I have
to okay so we're going to do the math my
moisturizer is $400 my eye cream is $300
my Serum is like another $300 my makeup
you know not included so if I have to
spend you know that's my money I'm
spending my money on these products I'm
going to use these products what are you
using them for though for myself okay
but I'm gonna use these products and I'm
going to show up because it's not like
I'm going to show up in sweats the man
doesn't owe you anything if you're just
getting to know each other if you're
inviting me out you owe me a day okay so
I I have a couple questions when I hear
this one why is her presence more
valuable than his presence yes women put
money and time and effort into their
looks men put time and effort into
building a career getting into good
shape they they put in hundreds of hours
to become the person that women want to
go on dates with so my question to her
is why is your
time more valuable than his and I
actually agree with the interviewer I
think in the beginning money doesn't
matter I know we're in 2023 a lot of
women expect that most men aren't even
too fussy about it but to me her
attitude is the problem it is
entitlement and if she feels entitled to
your money now what is is going to
change in 10 years when she takes you to
family court and the other thing that
people don't realize is chivalry is
actually gynocentric so what is
gynocentrism gynocentrism messes up the
natural order of the world I am Catholic
I believe the natural order of the world
goes God men women children I believe
women are most happy when they are
serving the men and what shivalry did is
actually it started with proposals so
men used to kneel to Kings and and that
goes with the natural order of the world
weaker men would submit to stronger men
okay so what they did was they replaced
the stronger man with a woman that's
gentric it's putting the men below the
women that is gynocentrism and that is
why we have all of the problems we have
today it's not just from a 100 years ago
it's not 200 years ago this goes back a
thousand years um so what she's asking
for is she's saying do all this for me
plan the date do all this for me and
serve me when really I I believe
relationships work when the women serve
the men that is the best strategy um so
let's pull up the next clip it's a black
dude with a microphone walking around
Miami and's saying to a girl hey girl
what's the minimum a man should spend on
the first date and she's like well I
used all my products I got ready I did
my makeup I don't know 200
bucks and everyone's clowning this chick
and clown world shared it and I agree
with 99% of what clown World say I think
I follow them they follow me we share
each other's stuff but I actually don't
think that woman did anything wrong I
don't think that woman said anything
wrong she's not grossly obese she's not
overtly ugly she's not overtly
unattractive she seems like a relatively
attractive woman she doesn't seem
outlandish or insane or wild in her ways
she's dressed very nicely she's
obviously put a lot of time into her
preparation you know it's not so much
about $200 being a set figure but let me
tell you something women deserve effort
when you take them on dates and when you
take women places they do deserve effort
because as much as I look amazing
tonight in my saval row tailored suit
with my Rolex watch on my alligator
shoes my thinning hair but still average
average hair give myself average for
hair as as good as I look it took me
about 4 minutes from getting out of the
shower to get ready hair Gil shirt
jacket pants shoes watch done that's it
you know men should always pay for dates
one never 50/50 because the man is
always the one asking the woman out you
as a young man going on a date are
trying to get a woman usually to give up
the most sacred thing that she has you
if you're going out to date on a woman
no matter how honest you are you can be
a good Christian man in which case
you're looking for more you want her
hand in marriage eventually you want her
to Bear your children that's what a
first day is it is an interview for the
most important thing a woman could
possibly give you she is interviewing
you and you have asked for that
opportunity to think
$200 is too much and that's obscene and
insane for a woman to want to go out on
a date where maybe the dinner's kind of
nice she has a few glasses of wine after
the 3 hours she's put in getting ready
shaving her legs all the that women
do I wanted to point out a couple things
I've noticed with the tape Brothers a
lot of times they'll give speeches and
they're still a bit gynocentric so what
is gynocentric it's always the woman is
on the pedestal the woman is above a man
I I wouldn't say simp um I can't imagine
that a guy with that much wealth status
Etc simps but I will say that his speech
is a little bit out of touch and he
really mischaracterized what she said he
said oh she was just asked with a
microphone and she's like yeah well $200
no no no she said $200 is being nice and
the truth of the matter is most women
will marry average men maybe she will
get a slightly above average guy but it
puts Tristan in a good situation because
he can say hey $200 that's nothing just
pay for dinner well that's easy to say
when you're a a multi-billionaire and
the truth of the matter is inflation is
through the roof there are average men
in this country that do important
infrastructure jobs and I really don't
like this idea that if a guy is Frugal
with his money that he then should not
date he does not deserve a woman um it
used to be that men that had good jobs
and were working could get a wife and
kids and that is not the case in 20123
for example 45% of men do infrastructure
jobs that means they drive the trucks
they pave the roads they build the
buildings they do the hard jobs in
society a lot of these men are average
earners let's say he wants to get a girl
girlriend right let's say he goes on a
date with four women in a month trying
to find a girlfriend or takes her on
four dates that's $1,000 a month that is
not feasible for the average man and a
lot of times what I see with these
influencers is they just get
overwhelmingly out of touch and I I
don't know why he's mischaracterizing
what she says the the next thing is he
talks about she takes four minutes to
get
ready well Tristan it it takes the guy
10 years to get ready to be at a point
where women want to go on dates with him
and that's why that's why I argue that
chivalry is putting a woman on a
pedestal because it's saying the man
should still do for the woman when
really the natural order of the world is
the woman submitting to the man and
doing for the man again the natural
order of the world is God men women
children women only truly love when they
are doing the most for a guy when they
are serving a man